le nombre de rapports sur la conquête de
l'espace a triplé en deux ans nous avons
besoin de ton expertise sur quel sujet
ça concerne un projet spatial russe
c'est moi et pour fera passer la
frontière c'est un document top secret
je suis président
je vais faire une mission en allemagne
je lui dis quoi
flahaut actuellement à londres
d'un autre côté on se connaît plus
sa cible est radagast
j'ai moins d'attaqués
sa fille
si vous voulez le par les nouveaux je
peux aider
je n'ai jamais l'occasion de parler avec
en français
et c'est l'équipe du doigt
au collège
je pense qu'on va lui faire confiance
bref de vivre en france je peux vous
aider reims et aux conséquences je peux
attaquer nos professeurs nous avons très
peu de temps
l'urss est un projet dont morby talent
capables de contourner tous les systèmes
de défense et ses modestes mais qui
tâche qu'ils utilisent
cette bombe n'est pas qu'un projet elle
est déjà en orbite à
euh
tu peux pas c'est le kgb l'écoutent on
ne peut plus continuer avec elle
le site à tout moment
totem le 18 février exclusivement sur
prime vidéo
[Musique]